[Music]
welcome to vatna yokel
icecap by volume the biggest in europe
it is a hard place to reach but when you
get here
it is captivating on this island of ice
and fire the ice here is discolored by
volcanic ash sprinkled over it by an
eruption a decade ago
the glacier can survive that but what
might kill it
is us as the world has warmed so the ice
in vatnayoko has melted faster and
faster
over the past 90 years this whole
glacier
has receded by five miles
snaver has been studying it for decades
you've come every year and it's got
smaller and smaller
and smaller what does it mean to you
it's uh
devastating actually it's a
it's uh surprising to see how
fast this happens you kind of
can't believe how thick the ice must
have been
about 100 years ago or 130 years ago
if i came back in five years time
where would i be standing probably on
ground this would all have gone yeah
the surface is lowering very rapidly the
retreat is is about
at this place it's about 100 meters per
year and
so three and three years four years yes
you will stand on on the soil
around him this glacier is eroding
before our eyes in real time
a very obvious victim of climate change
we know the
the the climate has been warming so
you it is a simple physic just go to a
shop and buy an ice cream and tell us
what happens when you go into
in into it it melts
iceland is losing so much heavy ice that
the country is
actually rising by about an inch every
year
a nation made by volcanoes is now being
shaped
by ice what strikes you when you come to
this glacier is not just the way in
which the environment is changing
but the speed at which those changes are
happening
and there is evidence of that look over
there
those cliffs are about 300 meters tall
and we know that a century ago this
glacier was exactly the same
height but after a hundred years of the
ice melting
those cliffs now tower above us
runs trips to the glacier to show the
effects but thanks to the global
pandemic and
iceland's introduction of a quarantine
for visitors his business has slipped
so it's gone from let's say half normal
in in mars to none throughout
april may june but then the island
opened up again in
let's say july august and it was back to
almost normal
but after the new rules it's been let's
say
almost almost none again in the winter
we had 10 people working for the company
and
sadly we had to lay everyone off and
that's probably
the thing that you sort of regret the
most
of seeing the job disappearing and
but we believe that this will change at
some point
we'll be able to recruit again behind
him water is
gushing into this huge lagoon it was
only formed 86 years ago
but from here you can see how the
glacier is falling
icebergs that have broken away and this
an ice cave collapsing as we watched
as long as the world is getting warmer
the glaciers will retreat
the natural order on this remote country
will change in a century or two
iceland could have very little ice
so in a country where nature is so
dominant the question is how to restore
that sense of equilibrium
and to answer that we need to leave
behind the ice and the glacier
but to think a bit more about that most
fundamental of things
[Music]
water
is a country that's learnt to live with
water in all its forms ice steam and
those
millions of liters melting from the
glacier water is part of the national
character here
iceland gets almost all of its energy
from renewable sources mostly from
hydropower it relies on the glaciers
but that plan only works if the glaciers
survive
the energy production in iceland has
been able to adopt to these changes
you can think of a glacier like a
battery you're draining stored energy
from the battery
but it will reach a peak if we go on
business as usual
within 150 200 years more or less all
glaciers will have disappeared
iceland will will more or less be
glacier-free
but i think we still have a chance to to
mitigate that
we push on towards the capital this is a
resilient nation
and there's a quiet hope that covet 19
will cause a new conversation about the
future of the world
in reykjavik's harbour the tourist
vessels are moored up
but the fishing boats are still going
out as the seas
change temperature so the weather has
become more volatile
and different types of fish are
appearing in the waters
so i asked the boss of one of the
biggest fishing companies
has covered distracted people from the
challenge of climate change
i don't think it has distracted us no
i really don't think so i think it has
made us more aware of
how vulnerable we are how vulnerable the
whole ecosystem is
so on the contrary i think it has made
us more aware
it has also shown us how resilient
people are
climate change are different but in the
minds of many people we spoke to what
links them
is a reliance on science on facts about
hyperbole
and maybe that is the legacy this
country really wants
in iceland we have put a lot of emphasis
in uh listening to
scientists during the pandemic the covet
outbreak
when it comes to climate change we have
also been listening to
to scientists and that is something that
the whole world needs to do
back on the glacier the ice continues to
melt
even the biggest icebergs hail will only
last a few weeks
this new giant lake the ice the cliffs
where the glacier one
sword they're all a warning about the
fragility of our ecosystem
the question is whether the world is
paying attention
adam parsons sky news fatneryokul
iceland
you